[Music]
we have a lot of stuff to talk about
tonight i want to start with the last
time you were here though you did a very
funny uh gave a very funny performance
the very unusual component to it i think
you know what i'm talking about yeah i
pushed a stool
you pushed a stool
there was a stool next to you and you
pushed it across the stage and you did
it for a really long time do people not
typically do that nobody does that and
then uh our director had the audio of
the sound that the stool made as it
scraped across the floor and for weeks
afterwards during rehearsal he would
randomly torture me can we can we hear
that
that just went on and on and on
it you know it plagues me too because i
can't go anywhere near a stool now or
any furniture really people are
horrified that i'm gonna start pushing
things around
it's one of my biggest problems these
days to be honest
i don't think so let's get to that
you were supposed to be on our show in
july but you had uh health issues how
are you
well i yeah i i pushed the stool around
and uh and then i was everything was
going great i was
doing stand up all around and
tv film play all sorts of things busy
and then all of a sudden my life just
nose dives and it really did nose dive
tell us it really did i got i got
pneumonia
and then i contracted this
life-threatening deadly illness called
um c diff and it's this bacteria that
just
eats your intestines and um
i was in the hospital for like a week
lost 20 pounds thank god
[Laughter]
finally got that whittled off my
waistline and um
and then um i got out of the hospital
and then it was my birthday
a couple days after the uh
hospital
happy birthday
to me
you had to sing it to yourself
yeah i did yeah
uh yeah it was my birthday and then a
few days after that my mother
uh passed away unexpectedly
uh
thank you a freak accident and then um
yeah it uh
i got out of a relationship shortly
after that
and then um
then i was diagnosed with cancer
please hold for
applause please be seated thank you so
much
um this was all in four months right it
all happened i mean immediately we were
all hearing about it but yeah event
after event after event and this cancer
diagnosis very serious yeah that's what
happened after the stool and you you
you make it sound like the comedy gods
were punishing you
for pushing his tool around i don't i
don't know i mean that's that's just
literally what happened i pushed the
stool and then
cancer
so you go in and you have
uh surgery
uh
yeah
yeah
i did
i uh i
well after i mean before that i was um
i i had found out that well i mean i was
i was supposed to do a show i was
supposed to do this american life and uh
so i was working on some new material
and um
and so ira glass the host had suggested
that i work on some new material and and
i had this show set up at largo and he
was like
the owner largo's a theater here here in
los angeles in los angeles and hollywood
yeah so i was going to perform there
and i had just left the doctor and the
doctor had told me that i had
stage two breast cancer in both breasts
and on the left side it was an invasive
tumor
that uh was not contained it had
possibly spread to my lymph nodes and
and i got the happy birthday
so you went to largo you gave this show
and louis ck who we mentioned in the
last segment uh who's an old friend of
ours uh comedian right here he's getting
there
if he can get a shot on this program
he'll have really made it um
louis ck tweets he goes and sees you
perform that night he was he was my
special guest right and i was going to
go on stage and do this material and i
was like oh my gosh i kept picturing
myself being the comedian that walks out
is like all right i've had a lot going
on
please bear with me and i was like i
can't go out and that's so lame to make
excuses for my performance and my brain
was like
what if you walked out and you were just
like hi thanks for coming i have cancer
just diagnosed and then i was like oh my
gosh i can't do that right and then i
kept laughing
and i was thinking what if somebody has
cancer though and i offend somebody and
i was like wait
i have cancer
[Laughter]
oh yeah i have cancer yeah so i kept
laughing about it and so yeah i went out
on stage and i was like hi i have cancer
and the audience was unbelievable they
were with me and and in the back of my
mind i kept thinking if this show goes
horribly at least i have louis c.k as my
surprise guest and he'll just slam dunk
this whole evening but it was an intense
evening where the audience was
crying and laughing and it was it was so
insane well louis watched a performance
and he tweeted it's the greatest
stand-up i've seen in his that he has
seen in his 27 year career what you did
that night
absolutely incredible
[Music]
louie's pretty good too i have to say
he still needs to get on this program uh
what does he tell us i i wish we had
more time
what is your latest prognosis
well i i had the surgery i had surgery i
did yeah uh double mastectomy
nobody's ever done that after they're
done
i hope that's not how your doctor told
me that gotta go
yeah
was your doctor the fonz
no uh
they uh they got all the cancer and it
did not spread
and uh my prognosis is great so
best news anybody here has heard in a
long time
yeah
i want to make sure i get to this uh
this is uh liv i'm pronouncing this
correctly yeah it's uh louis called me
the day after my performance he was in
san francisco with uh he was like i just
had lunch he was shooting a movie with
woody allen he said i just had lunch
with woody for two or three hours i was
telling him all about you and your
performance and i just think it's
important that this needs this needs to
be released this audio and he said i
want to release it from my website
exclusively
and uh
and so
it will be available
from louis ck's website
and it's called live because of the
figurative and literal
life and death of the material
that's on there but i also like the idea
that
people will always think it's tignotaro
live
and
i'll always have to
correct them and say no it's it's live
take your turo live is available at uh
louis ck.net for five dollars and a
portion of the proceeds will go to
charities associated with fighting
breast cancer we are so grateful that
you're on the mend and please come back
and see us i would love to thank
no tarot